[Musique]
foudre TV
ça ne me ferait pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
rendre ses
River des clous
[Musique]
je suis pas
pour combattre
[Musique]
je sais le froid
non je fais pas merci
de Patrick
avec moi mamie j'adore mais je connais
pas
tu veux faire le café des délices le
café délices
[Musique]
[Rires]
en fait
et voir ce que tu peux voir
[Applaudissements]
on m'avait dit
faut écouter son père
[Applaudissements]
le mien rien dit quand il se fait la
fête
pour toi
et j'ai grandi avec une place à prendre
c'est pour toi qui a le droit
qui a le droit
faire ça
[Musique]
vraiment
ce que disent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci à qui à quoi
à faire la pluie et le beau temps pour
des enfants
qui nous manque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour vivre ensemble
ça se vend toujours de s'aimer bien
alors c'est drôle on s'ennuyait et c'est
pas la peine si on pouvait des mots pour
se parler du mauvais temps alors
maintenant qu'il faut partir pour la 100
mille choses à vivre
au facteur pour si peu de temps
[Applaudissements]
à demain tu viens toujours un peu trop
vite
aux adultes quelquefois se passe un peu
trop
[Applaudissements]
allez je te fais un Britney Spears
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Britney Spears était là
elle était là elle était là elle était
là elle était là tu passes de Jonathan
puis je vous le demande je vous le
demande qu'est-ce que tu veux du clavier
un peu électro un peu ringardon
cette merde
[Applaudissements]
je suis un être à la recherche non pas
de la vérité mais simplement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette fille qui me tente alors je
cherche je
dis qui ne tente pas tu veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vient de faire partenaire particulier
[Applaudissements]
il se doit mettez-moi five
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non
je t'ai pas venu pour ça je t'ai pas
venu pour ça j'étais venu pour faire
Louane et je me retrouve à faire les
bacs il y a aucune il y a aucune logique
dans cette émission